Well an atom's made of protons, neutrons, and electrons
the first two in the nucleus, the third around it
it's mostly empty space, but it feels solid in any case
The elements are all the different types of atoms
they differ by the number of protons in the middle.
Hydrogen has only one,
but Uranium has a ton
It's just chemistry
that you and me
are made of these atoms
Well atoms bond together to form molecules
Most of what's surrounding me and you
Water, sugar, things yet undreamed of of of of
Look around you, see the combinations in a eucalypt tree
Mendeleev's periodicity
gives us sand and water and the air above ove ove ove ove
It's just chemistry
that you and me
are made of these atoms:
Hydrogen, Ox-y-gen, Carbon, Nitrogen,
make up the world's life forms
Do do do you, do do do do
but do you wonder how
matter forms something strange
when there's a chemical change?
Where did these atoms come from? They were fused in stars
Light elements combine releasing light from afar
Fusion in the sun,
creates Helium
I guess what I be saying is you gotta use your reason
To open up your mind and see the cause of the seasons
How do we know what's true?
The scientific method shows you
It's just chemistry
that you and me
are made of these atoms
Atoms bond together to form molecules
Most of what's surrounding me and you
Water, sugar, sand and you'll find things undreamed of
Argon, Neon, Xenon
There's no need to overstate
'Cause we are of course
This, of this, of this, we're made: atoms